[Music]
paul joins us in houston texas paul
welcome to the ramsay show
thank you thanks george thanks ken for
taking the call uh so
i'm new to the ramsey program itself um
i discovered it here trying to figure
out how to pay off all my debts and
before i had been doing some
probably
less than ideal things um with my
finances so
my question is with this pandemic
should i adhere to the one thousand
dollars
in an emergency fund or
should i have that
uh multiplied
by a certain amount
so you're wondering because of the
pandemic because of what's going on with
the economy how does this affect me do i
need to save up two thousand ten
thousand forty thousand in an emergency
fund
right right i've got some other
circumstances going but that's
besides the point but i wanna make sure
that
i'm doing everything i possibly can yeah
well paul since you're new to the plan
i'll go easy on you but there is no paul
caveat in the ramsey plan that says well
if your name's paul and you live in
houston yeah it's okay to save more the
purpose of this
is not to instill fear and have you
walking on thin ice the purpose of the
thousand dollars is to fuel you to pay
off all of your consumer debt to get you
the stability so if you have a little
fear i want you to i want you to be a
little bit uncomfortable because if when
you get comfortable you get broke
and so the purpose of this thousand
dollars is not to say hey if the hvac
goes out you're not gonna be able to
cover it the purpose is to get you angry
enough at this debt and get you scared
enough because you're not in a good
place right now when you have all this
debt so the purpose of that is to fuel
you through baby step two which is the
debt snowball paying off all of your
consumer debts except for the mortgage
to get you to baby step three where we
create this financial force field
between you and life between you and the
pandemic so you were talking about your
circumstances there paul what are those
circumstances
um
so
over the past about five years i've
doubled my income which is great awesome
but
i
unfortunately was letting someone else
manage the money um
and i discovered back in december just
how it was managed
it was definitely not um
in financial best interests was it a
spouse or what what do you mean someone
else was managing the money
it was a it was a spouse
uh
since since then i
had to take the reins and
it obviously caused a big turmoil and a
separation to occur i'm sorry i said
enough's
enough we've got
100 grand plus coming in
why why do we have 99 000 going out
so you weren't you guys obviously
weren't on the same page with money you
didn't know what was going on with the
money actually did financial peace a
number of years ago
but it didn't stick clearly obviously
obviously didn't um this was prior to
her and i meeting many years ago
so you guys are separated now is the is
there a divorce being finalized
uh
not as of yet but i need to get
everything on pace because i do have a
son that i have to take care of um
sorry to hear that paul
i'm 191
in the hole with
a mortgage
oh the mortgage what is the other type
of debt the non-mortgage debt that you
have credit card credit card vehicle um
back taxes um unpaid homeowners
association fees
what does that all add up to the
consumer debt uh about about 49 000. 49.
what's your your uh income
uh 1268.
and that's you solo which i'm guessing
you will be is your money separated yet
are you back in the range completely
separated okay so you got 126 coming in
and you have 49 in consumer debt so that
gives me hope because you've got a big
shovel uh and to me
this debt is gone in a year
with your with your take-home pay you
can absolutely crush this debt using the
debt snowball method
so what that is saying to me is you've
got a thousand dollars saved for a year
while you clean up this mess and then
you're going to very quickly get the
three to six months in place and have
that financial stability
yeah paul i got a question here is
george is walking you through this
you're very new to the ramsey solutions
process how's your budget right now you
got you got every dollar accounted for
you figured it out have you tightened
things up
i
definitely
accounted for every dollar here i
actually downloaded the um every dollar
app right a couple days ago and
started excel spreadsheet and after i've
already done
basically i started out doing baby step
three before anything
right
so but i've got an estate put up um now
what do you got what's in your baby step
three that's out of out of order what's
in it uh about
13 000.
okay so
you got 13 000 in cash right now
yes is that is that in addition to the
1000 or that includes the 1000 that we
say needs to be the emergency fund
that's including the 1000 emergency fund
okay well you heard george walk you
through this you heard george walk you
through this and i know you're new to it
but the reason that dave ramsey taught
it this way is because it's all about
psychology and momentum do you
understand there is some actual science
behind it it's not just dave's opinion
and the momentum is this
with a thousand dollars in your
emergency fund baby step one now you
take 12 000 today
what's the next
what's the smallest debt you've got
right now what is it
about 1200
okay what's next what's next is that a
credit card
yeah that's a small credit card all
right what's next after that
uh homeowner fees um another
almost 2 000. okay what's next after
that
another credit card well how much is
that one
uh 45
no i'm sorry 49.
okay i'm doing quick math here that's
got uh
yeah i'm counting we still got money to
spend how much what's next after that
we're wiping these out what's next after
that every by the way if you're keeping
up with me paul every one of these
things you're telling me you're paying
off with that twelve thousand today
right right and i also have a personal
loan um out because i did so uh upside
down real estate property i'm in
preparation for one how much is that
uh eight thousand okay we're not gonna
okay so we're not gonna get to that one
but the idea is is george walked you
through you're gonna go smallest largest
so we're gonna spend twelve thousand
dollars today before you go to bed
tonight you're wiping out several debts
we just got the three we don't have to
keep walking through this on the air and
paul what that does it takes you down to
37 and when you're making 126 you're
gonna clean this thing up in six or
seven months and you'll probably get
gazelle intense and want to take a side
job and work more and clean this thing
up even faster so that you can create
financial stability for yourself for
your kid that's what it's all about paul
that is why we teach the baby steps in
order and you got this man follow the
steps you can do it this is the ramsay
show